hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back who's out oh that's
already broken welcome back to condemned
where I'm about to bring the pain
to whatever lies in store her booze
whatever lies in store
too many mannequins up here whatever
lies in store in this horror filled and
bah ha ha you're real are you real or
you fakey fake ah
you're ill oh wait a minute
oh you're bringing this okay ha oh good
go out Winona yeah like I just not dying
oh what's wrong with your head face you
so ugly even your mama wouldn't love you
Oh why these guys were Santa today Santa
Kyah ha ha ha ha you killed Santa oh
those guys are tough you that of the
pipes out huh he'll sneak up on a guy
like that you'll scare him gonna kill ya
I could anti-war hey I saw you
was that investigator Ariel I knew it
where I was can't Bowl me blah blah blah
oops
mm actressy good job
right-handed right connects me sounds
good to me
this matches what we got from the crime
scene I processed all the prints you got
from the tape recorder at the metro
station isn't on this hand I don't get
it what what does that mean I'm not sure
christop in the same thing more
frustrating 200 the blood spatter I'm
such an idiot
I just saw a vision of someone getting
hit and blood spattering I didn't put
two and two together that I would need
to see yes blood droplet size and
dispersal pattern indicate I'm so stain
heavy blow [ __ ] hi I was not even
looking but hey what was that sound like
a lady nothing girl oh yeah tanka come
after I save this no no lady I don't
want to hurt you I want to hurt you
Wow you chose wrong oh oh just kind of
live I'm not dead you're dead
shoosh oh no no no thank you
ah all right are you real dude
ha how you startled me
what huh
sledgehammer I don't have a sledgehammer
her Bush you real it dummy but real
right now
you don't even real right now so there
we Franck
goddamnit I don't flash ever give me
yep yep yep all right okay vision loo
Boosh I have on sledgehammer in Hyneman
Chris poor Ivan is fit is good mm huh in
a real ha ha ha oh yes right on over
here oh wait it's gonna hide over there
all right I don't need to fight you OOP
thanks yeah like a mouse okay I'll save
that's cool close the door honey
look it's more health food don't know
why that one needed a sledgehammer
besides the fact that had a padlock and
obviously you can only break padlock off
with a sledgehammer
hello oh hey oh yeah
how oh well no gun I'll be gun how many
bullets you have Oh block that here's
that they got like a power strap going
on
come Oh cloud of blood oh I like my
slippers like coated with blood yes I
like that I like that a lot
ah no you're not coming after me oh yes
right on down that guy's got a shotgun I
will investigate after I kill this guy
Wow oh yeah they came out of the
elevator
huh here we are and go this way and
they'll hear and break this down with my
sledgehammer find an alternate route ah
where you go brother
with the twin out Oh seriously
who is making these guys with the
freaking Monica like plaster on their
heads weird
wonderful sledgehammer ever loses
durability I don't know I don't know huh
no I'm not paid to worry about those
things
hello hello is this my alternate route
is this my alternate route route
oh hello lady puppet sorry
oh hey wow you're tough you're tough for
a dame oh hello I wonder if anyone in
this game can move faster than one meter
per hour for your you Europeans up there
da hey he's got a shotgun
I want it sooo Biscay hey blammo flower
go sir flabbergasted
ramrod ramrod cover up there oh no no
move your faces ah how boo
uncle OS bull oh that's a load of bull
lady I don't even have time to deal with
your bull - there's a health pack over
here
uh it's so much better I slam all the
pills down my throat all at once oh
there was a health pack right here - I'm
an idiot
okay that was my fault I was obviously
my fault but I'm gonna blame them anyway
you all are gonna blame them - if you
know what's good for you good Oh give me
that
please ball take that oh yeah oh yeah
Tom get Tom evil
I'm through
the biskits oh I don't want to jump down
jump down sounds like a bad idea
Oh No
whose Oh
oh look at that
Oh
Oh No well that's an actual guy that's a
guy go stump as a mannequin I think
ha ha ha ha
ok I already have bullets
I guess I'm going down it's good party
blue
I swear laser drag marks here we go
probably dead bird over there but I
don't really care
yeah I knew it was coming I knew there
was gonna be a mannequin part yeah
collect take a picture of nothingness Oh
footprint look compiling
cross-referencing footprint is an exact
match to the ring I mounted the metro
station car it may be the matchmaker
that's tell about that rogue fingerprint
from the table whoa keep following the
trail and mate answers maybe truth is I
would if I could but this part of the
department store is flooded his trail
ends here
it might be a long shot but try using
your gas spectrometer why what body
start to get immediatly producing
hydrogen sulfide and traces of man oh
you mean my bird finder I only use that
for finding birds look the air sample
contains usual oh oh oh okay oh hey oh
hey hi there hi hi boom
those guys I can handle mannequins
shudder
shudder to think hello is anybody here
who a dead bird
oh boy I'm not gonna waste that on you
I can't block you gonna get punched get
ready for the pouch
Oh favorite one punch their face right
off
oh that's where the movie faceoff got is
then Oh cuz I pushed it based off of it
ah ah no ah no good gravy
wait bar X I built a good one all right
I probably need this for something
they even go the right way I'm my bird
finder tells me that I'm not where I
need to be yep aerial patrol Biscay zach
is this look how I well hello what the
hell I'm Luke me in a circle what's even
the point of that door it was even the
point of this door oh wait a minute this
is where I dropped in oh oh wait no I'm
going in a circle
ah come on I need this ring
oh hello oh hi lady
come on baby oh wow you got some reach
on you don't there's one star baby you
made me I didn't choose to be this
monster am I gonna right way now yes yes
ooh that's a breakable door so the other
one flip sure lock mouth and wish it was
in the yellow that one goes upstairs
probably where I need to be what the
hell that
unlike that was this Oh
I'm actually quite curious what's going
on there anyway I'll have to figure out
later cuz I am all out of time thank you
all so much for watching check the other
annotations for other videos that I've
done and has always will stay you in the
next part
bye